and in alberta protesters are again
blocking traffic at the coots border
crossing that blockade resumed late
tuesday protesters say they will stay
put even though alberta's premier has
ended the proof of vaccination
requirement there heather urex west is
near milk river where an encampment of
supporters is growing heather how have
the rcmp stepped up enforcement
they have been issuing a soft touch
enforcement plan is what they call it
issuing tickets and asking protesters to
leave that has not been successful so
far the border remains blocked in this
encampment
has grown this afternoon is about a
kilometer worth of people and trucks
here camping in the ditch and on the
highway and protesters that we've spoken
with say that they are here for the long
haul even with rcmp issuing tickets they
say that until
vaccine mandates and covert restrictions
are lifted not only
in alberta but across the country
until those go away they say that they
will stay put
i just feel that we have to stand for
freedom i know that the more people that
we have standing for freedom
the stronger we all together a ticket to
me is a small price to pay at this point
standing your ground means standing your
ground holding your hold the line
that's that's very easy statement and so
you can read into that but plain and
simple it's people are not going to back
down
so they say they're not moving heather i
guess that means the rcmp have to do
something else what does it mean for the
border crossing itself
yeah it is completely blocked i can tell
you yesterday there were about 70 trucks
lined up here in milk river hoping to
get across the border that traffic has
since left either returning home or in
search of another route into the u.s now
the rcmp did tell us in an update
yesterday that protesters do need to go
and that their goal is to reopen traffic
uh flowing across the border we have
asked them today what they plan to do
next given that their soft touch
approach with ticketing does not seem to
be working we have not received an
answer so at this point it appears to be
an impasse here in southern alberta
donna
okay heather urix west near milk river
alberta tonight thanks